[Musica]
buongiorno buongiorno a tutti e tutte
sono molto felice di essere qui con voi
questa mattina e ho pensato di parlarvi
della mia passione
rivolta alla crescita e allo sviluppo di
una idea che è diventato anche un grande
movimento internazionale
il movimento della impact economy e ho
pensato di farlo partendo da due parole
una naturalmente è impact revolution
cioè la rivoluzione dell'economia impact
di cui vi parlerò
però voglio partire da un'altra parola
che la parola consapevolezza
perché consapevolezza anzi direi quasi
consapevolezza
aumentata perché io credo che in questo
momento anche drammatico del nostro
tempo in cui sono entrate due parole
orribili
una sconosciuta a tutti noi fino a poco
tempo fa
covic e l'altra che immaginavamo
espulsa dal
dalla dimensione civile e sociale del
nostro tempo la guerra due parole
covi e guerra che hanno un minimo comune
denominatore anzi diciamo guerra di
aggressione di putin all'ucraina
diciamolo bene
il comun denominatore di queste due
parole è la paura
è la paura e la paralisi però siamo in
un'università io quindi ho pensato siamo
in uno spazio di costruzione di
progettazione di futuro
siamo uno spazio di speranza e quindi io
ho pensato di volervi raccontare invece
un mondo di consapevolezza aumentata che
sta producendo degli effetti molto
concreti sull'economia
allora la consapevolezza io penso che
possiamo tutto tutti riconoscere il
fatto che è come se fossimo tutti più
consapevoli
della interconnessione tra di noi
della fragilità degli ecosistemi del
pianeta
dell'urgenza di colmare
processi diseguali tari che stanno che
stanno creando squilibri
drammatici nel nostro tempo e credo che
questa consapevolezza si si può
incardinare a livello individuale
soggettivo nei nostri gesti nelle nostre
scelte e le nostre opzioni di consumo ma
anche ad un livello più alto cioè o
diciamo così più generale che il livello
dell'azione delle organizzazioni
economiche
allora
da questo punto di vista
la sfida della impact economy è
veramente una rivoluzione ed è di questo
che vi voglio parlare
fino io sono un economista di formazione
tra l'altro laureata alla sapienza una
allieva un'alunna di federico caffè
che ci insegnava già all'epoca già al
tempo che l'economia produceva delle
esternalità grandi economisti si sono
occupati di questo quest'esterna lì oggi
nel linguaggio contemporaneo le
chiamiamo impatto cioè la generatività o
non generatività di un'attività
economica di un investimento di una
produzione
il capitalismo ha vinto ha vinto nel
mondo
però deve sapersi autoriformare perché
il capitalismo fondato
sulla nozione dell'ottimizzazione del
profitto che quella nozione anzi sulla
nozione dell'ottimizzazione del profitto
e della valutazione di due fattori
solamente cioè il rischio di un'attività
economica e il suo rendimento non sono
più sufficienti ad affrontare i temi
importanti del nostro tempo abbiamo
bisogno io dico spesso uso questo
termine
sintetico abbiamo bisogno di un
capitalismo 3d
abbiamo bisogno di ottimizzare
rischio rendimento e impatto
abbiamo bisogno di misurare per ogni
attività economica produttiva ogni
investimento
l'impatto che genera o non genera
l'impatto ambientale
energetico sociale
l'impatto sui temi della parità di
genere di generazione di territorio
insomma introdurre nella logica della
allocazione delle risorse
questa terza dimensione
e allora che cosa significa questo io
tra l'altro vi parlo come
da questo punto di vista come
presidente di uman foundation una
fondazione che abbiamo creato circa
dieci anni fa per portare questa cultura
dell'investimento d'impatto e
dell'economia di impatto in italia e
come punto diciamo di aggregazione
nazionale di una grande rete e vi voglio
dare qualche dato su questo perché
quando nel 2010
iniziamo a parlare di impact con home
italia e in italia devo dire era
ostrogoto letteralmente ostrogoto oggi
oggi no oggi comincia a essere entrato
nel linguaggio mainstream dei decisori
pubbliche anche delle imprese e gli
investimenti ad impatto nel mondo erano
poco più di 40 50 miliardi di dollari
investiti cioè investimenti che
intenzionalmente
oltre a cercare di minimizzare il
rischio e ottimizzare il profitto
intenzionalmente definivano qual era
l'obiettivo di impatto che volevano
generare poi vi parlerò di come si
misura questo impatto perché quella è
l'infrastruttura
intangibile del paradigma della impact
economy bene quindi stavo dicendo pochi
poche decine di miliardi di dollari
investiti su masse finanziarie investite
su scala globale
una goccia nell'oceano diciamo la verità
una goccia nell'oceano ecco oggi
oggi
stiamo parlando di
allora le masse finanziarie investite
nel mondo oggi sono circa 150 adesso poi
ovviamente dipende dalle oscillazioni
siamo cioè 340 150 trilioni di dollari
e questo è il mercato finanziario
globale
in questo mercato finanziario globale
oggi si
autodefiniscono
iris di investimenti jesi g quindi
investimenti che teoricamente
devono
diciamo così non produrre danni dal
punto di vista ambientale energetico
delle disuguaglianze sociali
nelle quita della governance si
autodefiniscono investimenti di circa
40 trilioni
di dollari d'investimento
quella allora intanto dico subito che se
fosse veramente così se questi 40
trilioni di dollari investiti in
investimenti ilva momento social and
governance e compliance fossero davvero
così tanti probabilmente molti dei
problemi che oggi stiamo affrontando non
ci sarebbero quindi diciamo subito che
finché non c'è una griglia molto precisa
per definire gli investimenti chigi
il rischio del green social
governance washing è molto alto e vi
devo anche dire che
una buona notizia ancora una volta prima
abbiamo sentito le buone notizie sul
tema del digital divided e della
protezione dei dati personali da un
intervento precedente io vi voglio dire
che un'altra buona notizia ancora una
volta viene dall'europa perché è
l'europa che ha precisamente con un
regolamento che anche un numero si
chiama 20 88 definito qualche qualche
anno fa e adesso è nella fase di
attuazione che cosa è la finanza
sostenibile
e nella definizione di finanza
sostenibile c'è la finanza e g e c'è la
finanza d'impatto che è quella verso cui
dobbiamo tendere perché diciamo così
l'alimentatore della rivoluzione della
impact economy quindi
140 trilioni di dollari le masse
finanziarie investite circa 40 trilioni
di dollari gli investimenti che oggi si
autodefiniscono
psg
circa 2 miliardi quelli erano trilioni
questi sono miliardi i dollari di
investimenti ad impatto
qual è la differenza tra gli
investimenti e di impatto e gli
investimenti e g
la differenza che negli investimenti ad
impatto
il presupposto non è non faccio da anni
non inquino
il presupposto è risolvo un problema
ambientale sociale cioè un investimento
proattivo che e torno al discorso di
prima vuole
esplicitamente ottimizzare rischio
rendimento e d'impatto questa è la
impact revolution a cui io mi sono
appassionata per tanti motivi intanto
perché non delega solo all'istituzione
pubblica la
risoluzione dei tanti problemi che
abbiamo non delega solo all'attore
pubblico la responsabilità di rendere il
mondo il nostro paese e l'europa un
posto migliore e tira dentro la sfida
gigante del cambiamento
sociale ambientale il i privati i fondi
le imprese
i grandi fondi finanziari insomma
responsabilizza il capitalismo ad
autoriformarsi a trovare strumenti
concreti di contrasto
all'ingiustizia sociale ambientale è
fatemelo dire così l'exit strategy
ad un capitalismo che ha purtroppo
portato con sé una scia di ingiustizia
di povertà e di distruzione degli
ecosistemi sono strumenti concreti
pragmatici
che in questi ultimi minuti voglio
descrivervi sono forse qualcuno di voi
ne avrà sentito parlare si chiamano
social impact box refugee bones
environmental bonus outcome fans
purtroppo i nomi sono tutti in inglese
perché è un movimento che pensate quando
con uman cominciammo nel 2010 a lavorare
su questi temi è veramente oltre ai
alla misura degli investimenti investiti
nel mondo che appunto come ho detto
erano molto molto minori ma anche la
diffusione di questo movimento oggi la
rete del globo in gruppo sympak
investment che la rete che unisce tutti
gli attori della rivoluzione impatta in
38 paesi al mondo nel 2012 era in sette
paesi al mondo questo anche per darvi
una dimensione della forza di questo
movimento e quindi dicevo sono tutti
strumenti che funzionano così provo a
raccontarvelo molto sinteticamente nella
triangolazione tra un decisore pubblico
governo regione ente locale che
definisce un obiettivo per esempio
ridurre il drop out scolastico per
esempio integrare
rifugiati e migranti per esempio ridurre
quella enorme area di neet di ragazzi
che non studiano non lavorano con
politiche attive per il lavoro
gli obiettivi sono dati dal dal decisore
pubblico dalle istituzioni pubbliche su
quegli obiettivi si sfida il settore
privato e si collega al raggiungimento
di quegli obiettivi anche un rendimento
dell'investimento
questo cosa significa significa che
stiamo provando gradualmente a spostare
il ruolo delle imprese
da
filantropi da oltre cioè a integrare
nell'identità di un'impresa il ruolo di
produzione di reddito attraverso
l'attività dell'impresa e il ruolo della
sia sardo impresa della filantropia
della donazione cioè il social impact
bond tipicamente funziona così c'è un
investitore che mette delle risorse per
realizzare un obiettivo sociale
ambientale di parità di genere definito
dallo stato quando quell obiettivo sarà
raggiunto
il capitale investito dal
dall'investitore sarà restituito con un
rendimento che naturalmente non è mai un
rendimento speculativo ma è un
rendimento il capitale deve produrre e
maturare un rendimento questa
triangolazione io credo che qualcosa di
cui il nostro paese ha grandissimo
bisogno
per non sedersi e immaginare che le
risorse pubbliche possono risolvere
tutto anche se noi ora siamo in una fase
nel nostro paese di diciamo così
espansione della spesa pubblica ma non
sarà così in eterno per attivare una
capacità imprenditoriale questo lo dico
mi rivolgo in particolare a voi ai
ragazzi noi abbiamo bisogno
di imprenditori
consapevoli ecco e contorno alla parola
iniziale che ho scelto per partire
consapevoli del fatto che ogni nostro
gesto ogni nostro investimento ogni
nostro consumo porta con sé degli
effetti degli infatti abbiamo bisogno di
cody imprenditori consapevoli visionari
che
si
pongano l'obiettivo di ottimizzare
rischio rendimento ed impatto ea cui non
basta più immaginario solo la
massimizzazione del profitto
questa è la impact revolution questo è
il paradigma della impact economy questo
è il mondo per cui e gli strumenti molto
concreti per cui stiamo lavorando con
umane con il movimento importa molto
tempo un'ultima cosa voglio dirvi ho
visto che il mio tempo è scaduto quindi
veramente un telegramma c'è un
infrastruttura
intangibile però fondamentale per la
rivoluzione della impact economy che è
la misurazione dell'impatto questo ci
porterebbe a una riflessione filosofica
molto interessante pensate che i mercati
di capitale ancora oggi sono regolate da
forme di rendicontazione che sono quelle
che derivano dalla dal dal dibattito
conclusosi dopo la seconda guerra
mondiale non è più possibile questo noi
dobbiamo avere
integrare la rendicontazione
finanziaria i bilanci delle aziende con
una rendicontazione sociale ambientale
di genere non separata io non credo più
lo dico in maniera un po provocatoria
non credo più nei bilanci ambientali nei
bilanci sociali nei bilanci di
sostenibilità no dobbiamo andare verso
ve lo dico in inglese perché è anche un
grande progetto a cui stiamo lavorando
in pace
oddio vabbè rendicontazione finanziaria
che pesa anche gli impatti in parte
account ecco impact waiter account io
non so quanti di voi ragazzi qui state
studiando economia o state studiando
giurisprudenza o scienze politiche o
comunque materie che vi con cui vi state
misurando anche con i temi di come si
rendiconta l'attività di una di
un'organizzazione economica la
rivoluzione della sostenibilità parte
anche da lì come parte da lì la
consapevolezza nostra individuale ma
anche delle organizzazioni e delle
imprese che dobbiamo assolutamente
cambiare rotta per costruire quella exit
strategy a un capitalismo finora troppo
energivoro disuguale e non giusto grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]